The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at owc.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So we have
a list L, originally,
[life, answer, 42, 0].
In this example,
if you don't know
Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy,
that's why 42 is important.
As a scientist, if I
didn't at least one example
with the number 42, I'd
probably hear about it.
So here it is.
OK, so we have this
original list L,
which contains the
string "life", the string
"answer", the number
42, and the number 0.
Here, I'm writing a loop that
iterates over every element
directly in L, right?
So originally, thing is going
to be string "life", then, thing
is going to be the
string "answer", then,
thing is going to
be the number 42.
And so what am I doing inside
the loop as I'm iterating?
Well, if thing is equal to
0, then I'm going to do this.
And otherwise, I'm
going to do this.
So for the first
two iterations when
thing is equal to
"life" or "answer",
I'm not doing anything.
As soon as I hit 42 though,
I'm saying, L, at position 1,
is going to get
this value here, OK?
So when I've iterated over this
element here, I'm saying L,
at position 1, I'm going to
change its value, which says,
well, I'm going to
keep "life" the same,
but this is going
to be "everything".
And then we're keeping the
rest the same, 42 and 0,
because we're only
modifying L at position 1.
As soon as we do
that, we've finished
with the loop when L was 42.
And then we go through 0.
So now, thing takes
on the value 0.
And we say, if thing is equal
to 0, well, we're good on that.
L, at position thing,
is equal to "universe".
So L, at position 0,
So that says, OK, I'm going to
replace "life" with "universe".
And then everything else
stays the same-- 42 and 0, OK?
So that would be my answer,
[universe, everything, 42, 0].
Great, that's the majority.
Good job.